greetings apiece welcome to the DS show
I'm Eddie your host and this week on the
Dean show we're gonna be talking about a
fascinating story about a young man who
had a young age was going to the church
with his grandmother and then he became
a staunch atheist joined the military
had this blind hatred of Islam now he's
on the D show let's hear what he has to
say we'll be right back
this is the assalamu alaikum peace be
with you ali Cammarata how are you
brother I'm doing good hyung do that all
right I'll write it now before I when I
open the show I talked about you
formally being in the military white
American had really a was a staunch
atheist then a born-again Christian is
this pretty much how it happened the
stuff yeah yeah throughout high school I
became an atheist then later on a
Christian again before researching
Islamic or an eleven yes let's start
from when your grandma used to take you
to church let's start from those those
days okay well when I was a little kid
my grandma was the most religious person
in the family she used to take me to
church almost every Sunday she was
Luther and I went to the Bible study on
Wednesdays and basically spent my
summers you know in Christian groups and
Bible studies and things like that
yeah that was it yeah so around how old
were you at that time this was ever
since I was little or as far as I
remember until later when I got to about
like middle school age or so that's when
I really didn't go to those events as
much going into high school so how do
you go from Grandma taking you to the
church to becoming not only an atheist
just are really a staunch atheist as you
mentioned I mean I was raised I knew I
had a lot of knowledge of it you know I
went to grow all the motions as a kid
but at the high school age I stopped
going to church as much and then mostly
it was during like biology classes a lot
of the teachers even though religions
not supposed to be spoke about in school
a lot of times when they're talking
about stuff like evolution and why not
you notice the teachers their authority
figures
it's so you know sometimes they
interject their atheist belief during
the high school years and actually had a
lot of conversations with two specific
teachers and they really convinced me of
their way so when I was making about 14
or 15 their side made a decision that
you know atheism is the truth that it's
based on science and everybody else is
just crazy nut jobs to believe anything
else and you know I've basically made my
mind up that in order to be religious
you have to turn your mind off and from
there on I basically was very against
religion for a few years so you totally
at that point left religion altogether
yeah I mean I hadn't taken maybe one or
two years before becoming a since where
I wasn't really practicing as a
Christian and then when I became an
atheist I wrote I my basic outlook was
that everybody who believes in the
religion they must be you know not able
to thinker and they must not know
science or something along those lines
now how grandma what grandma have to say
about this after you told her that you
made this decision I didn't really have
any discussions with her about that you
know it was my grandma but you know it
was mostly something that I talked to
people my own age about I wasn't wishing
that on anybody at the time it was just
something that I mostly believe strongly
myself from there you went out to join
the military tell us about this yeah I
joined the military early when I was 17
right after my birthday I did the early
enrollment which means that you get to
do half the training you got to finish
high school and then go back for the
other half I signed up you know I got
the they were gonna pay for the college
I had no problem with the army I I
thought it'd be a good experience for
career path with her name for college
obviously and other things but also
because I felt like it was a good move
responsibility wise and after joining
the military that's when I went to basic
training out of 17 this is all before I
was missing yeah so and this was you
went to you joined the military was this
before 9/11 or after 9/11 this was
actually the year of 9/11 but in March
that year so it was right after I turned
17 before 9/11 so it was what was the
was the the hostilities that we
see towards Islam and Muslims was it
anywhere near where it is today back
then I grew up in a medium-sized city
and Erie Pennsylvania has about a
million people but I never met a Muslim
my whole life growing up we didn't we
don't have many international races or
anything not many immigrants this is a
smaller city in the military I mean I
can't remember the word Islam or Muslims
coming up before 9/11 even in the
military there's basically a non-issue
nobody knew about it nobody talked about
it it didn't come up as much in the
media and then even in basic training
that first year when I was 17 I went
that summer which was just a few months
before 9/11 most of the time they were
talking about communism in Russia and
history have that and then Vietnam War
you know those are mainly the enemies
they would talk about before 9/11 so
Muslims never really came up now you
talk about in your story that you you
ended up having like most people just as
blind hate of Islam what do you mean you
just had a blind hate of Islam what does
that mean I came back from basic
trainings I did the early entrance
program I didn't have the normal 16
weeks I did eight weeks I came back I
was playing football for my school
retirement when I returned it was about
two weeks before school started and 9/11
happened about the week after that so I
just got back from basic training maybe
about three weeks later you know basic
training you spent eight weeks with the
military you wake up in the barracks you
sleep in the barracks and polish your
boots every night you have a half hour
to write letters the rest of the day is
completely you know you're into the
system of this military way of thinking
you have the community like the
Brotherhood of the military stuff like
that and three of my friends also had
done the early entrance so in the early
entrance program I had three friends in
my same grade Suellen were also on the
football team with me so we all came
back from basic training and three weeks
later at 9/11 happens and being new in
the army we were also thinking like
maybe we're going to get deployed
because you know something happened
maybe we're going to have to go Iraq or
I don't know they weren't discussing
Iraq mostly Afghanistan back then but
after this 9/11 happened especially
being a military I had this beautiful a
Husker
them and these people attacked us and
everything on the media course is gonna
be one way so I was overcome mostly by
the media and by the us versus them
mentality and you know it was basically
like a fight type of attitude and I had
the blind hatred because I saw them as
the enemy and that's the way they were
always made out to be so now you come
back from the military and how was your
perception so did it you you go from
being a born-again Christian you I'm
sorry you go from going to church with
your grandmother then you end up
becoming a stunt staunch atheist you
joined the military and somewhere in
there you end up becoming a born-again
Christian actually at the time that I
joined the military I was a little bit I
was starting to question some of the
Atheist presumptions you know the
assumptions they make about this is
against religion this is with religion
it I had some questions in my mind a few
doubts when I joining the military
actually every Sunday you have the
choice and in basic training you can't
go to you know I don't know if they've
changed it but you can't go to gym or
anything Sunday is the only religious
day and in the military you can
basically stay back with the drill
sergeants and clean or you can go to the
church so even the atheist went to
church during the basic training and
they mostly fell asleep in the back but
I went every Sunday for church some of
the things that were said we're a little
bit inspiring at the time I took a Bible
with me and started reading it every day
and then even when I got home before
9/11 I started reading a lot and that's
the time where I got buried back
involved with Christianity maybe a month
before 9/11 two months and I was born
again at that time I went through the
process I was born again overcome with
the Spirit of Christ all this stuff to
talk about
but at that time I really became a
practicing Christian again after you
know reading about the religion and
everything and that happened after the
military all right let's hold off right
there we're gonna take a break and we
right back with more to hear about this
incredible story here on the Dean shell
don't go anywhere
Slavic terrorism
misconception Muslims are terrorists
this is by far the biggest misconception
of Islam given unfairly by stereotyping
in the public image that the media gives
has anyone else noticed how when a
specific group of people attack another
group of people it is labeled as a hate
crime but when a Muslim opens fire on
anybody it is quickly regarded as
terrorism many political dictators and
officials or extremist groups use the
name of Islam as a strategy to garner
followers and attention when many of
their practices go against the true
basis of Islam the media has also
portrayed Islam as a cult or a club
where if you join you become a terrorist
and that is now part of your agenda
however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quran that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
offense another verse states if they
seek peace then you seek peace which
means do not attack people for no reason
or kill innocent people there is nowhere
in Islam whether it be in the Koran or
the teachings of Muhammad that promotes
the killing of innocent people
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show and we're talking
to a gentleman Ali who went from going
to church with your grandmother to
becoming a staunch atheist joining the
military and then becoming a born-again
Christian that's where we left us left
off
please continue from here so you're a
born-again Christian now what happened
what happens in your life now yeah I was
born again Christian while I was in the
military and like I said that was the
first half of my training
part of the early entrance program was I
didn't have training but you have to
have a high school diploma or GED so I
went back to my senior year of high
school maybe three weeks before 9/11
happened I came back from the military
after 9/11 happened you know the normal
media craze and also being in the
military as seeing them as an enemy
I had the blind hatred you know there
was in my mind every Muslim was an Arab
they were backwards to the Stone Age
people in blue love our buildings you
know attacked us and everything you know
it's the whole us vs. them mentality you
know for maybe a good two three months
you know there would be jokes and family
gatherings you know friends would make
you know different jokes about Muslims
and you know now that you think back on
it you know it's basically a modern day
of racism we'd never say something about
black people were straight you know but
at that environment at the time
everybody hated Muslims so it was kind
of going with the flow but also I
internalized as well hating these other
people that would attack us
you know for maybe about the next two
three months that's all it was just
lying hatred I didn't know anything
about his song but I hated it you
despite having no knowledge talk to talk
to us about this class project that you
had that it was an easy a and easy pass
if you did it and what was it on yeah
actually
being my senior year I only needed a few
credits so I took a few of those easy
classes you know that you don't have to
light thing in and it was a drafting
class you know Cadden doing different
stuff and we had a project that was due
after Christmas if you make up a board
game and the teacher said that if you
make a board game using the draft
techniques if it's an original idea
you're gonna automatic pay for class
even if you don't show up so you know
everybody wanted a little effort in it
and he said if it was a unique idea that
he's never seen before I would get an
automatic a and everybody would so being
after 9/11 I decided to make a concept
that I'm gonna kill a full song bill on
and you know you roll dice eventually
fly to Afghanistan land on the square
you pick up a weapon you land on another
square you pick up something it was like
a board game and the whole plot was to
kill Osama bin one I finished this
before Christmas break and it was due
afterwards so I decided to take it home
with me I was gonna draw some graphics
on it you know some extra images to make
the board game good because acing the
board game meant an easy second half of
the year and actually that's when I was
gonna I looked up some pictures I forgot
what a turbine look like and one of the
squares you landed on was Somali Osama
bin Laden's turban on fire and that was
the way of killing him so I wanted to
look up an image and draw it on the game
board as an illustration and that's
actually when I jumped on Google started
typing and turbines and one of the first
sites that came across was the Aslam
guide calm that brief illustrated guide
to Islamic I remember one paragraph
specifically it may have been first or a
second but it said that Islam believes
in the prophets of Adam and Noah and
Abraham and lot and Moses and Jesus and
that blew me back because all I ever
heard is that these people believed that
the more disbelievers they kill before
they die the better they're in heaven
you know the 72 virgins and everything
so reading that they believe in the
prophets was shocking for me I had a
blind patron but no knowledge so once I
saw that I realized you know I hate
these people but I don't even really
know what I can I mean how can you truly
hit a something if you don't know it and
then combined with my new my waking bull
run again for about the last maybe five
six months at the time I also asked
myself how can I truly be call myself a
Christian if that's the only religion I
ever even know anything about and I was
confident in Christian said you know I'm
gonna know more about these Muslims
because they're bad people
but I want to understand them but also
you know Christianity is the truth so no
matter what I read I'm still gonna be a
Christian I'm still gonna reaffirm my
faith so that's when I started reading
and that was basically the first
Christmas vacation so I had no school
for a week or two and I just started
reading basically non-stop for a week or
two and that was my first exposure to
Salaam I never met a Muslim I I didn't
even know they believed in the prophets
and then that was basically from zero I
started reading tell us about Joseph you
mentioned a retired 20 year veteran in
who was in the Navy he was also a Muslim
that you hooked up with tell us about
this experience okay yeah from the where
I left off the part of reading you know
basically I started reading a couple
days before Christmas or around
Christmas and it becoming a Muslim after
one week because I really I dedicate
myself to reading 1012 even 14 hours a
day from waking the sleeping it I became
Muslim after learning about it
but after that I didn't know anybody I
told some people online I mean some of
the support groups that are around now
even like Facebook stuff like that
wasn't available back then so I kept
Islam to myself I emailed an MSA and got
an email back that hey that's not really
an MSA it was just two of us and we
graduated but I have a couple friends
you can talk to him he was one of the
guys ended up finding through AOL
Instant Messenger and he was working for
care down in Washington DC and I'm about
a seven hour drive away from me and I
remember mentioning to him I was
military he was military we both heard
and he said so how is your Muslim
Caminos like what do you mean I haven't
met a Muslim yet and actually the
brother much don't let me all to reward
him you know instantly he was like what
you didn't meet a Muslim you need to
meet a Muslim so he actually drove up
seven hours to meet me
we ate some Chinese food together gave
me a couple things and another brother
from New Jersey actually mailed me some
stuff from an Islamic bookstore website
and then after meeting him he said hey I
got work in the morning I go oh so I
only saw him for an hour but mashallah
brother drove to see me and that gave me
a good impression of Brotherhood early
on because at the time I still hadn't
told any of my family and friends that I
was Muslim they actually found out about
four months later you still keep in
contact with fraud Joseph yeah I see him
online now we're in different countries
and stuff but I still contact them as
much as we can we're both kind of busy
but you know I'm over Facebook in
chanting SEM you want to give them the
salams before we go to break to Joseph
that was actually the first Muslim white
American who are accepted Islam go ahead
this is this one this allows for you
Joseph if you're out there from our
brother Ali all right we're going to be
right back with more of this wonderful
story here in the Dean shell don't go
anywhere
please subscribe to the video follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we left off with
Joseph coming to see you right and then
so before that you already had accepted
you accepted that there's nothing worthy
of worship except the creator of the
heavens an herb the same God that Jesus
worship Moses Abraham you weren't doing
anything different you even have a beard
now
I mean I mean this is a part of Islam
but some people tuning in a lot of the
not yet Muslims they heard you say Osama
bin Laden and they've heard 9/11 they
see you with a big beard Muslim I mean
that's like a formula for a disaster for
some people what do you have to say when
people you know they have these negative
perceptions of Islam due to the negative
propaganda what do you say to them I
mean I couldn't bear witness myself that
I was in the military I was you know I
didn't convert to be a terrorist or
anything like that I had a healthy hate
for you know anybody that would kill
innocent lives after becoming Muslim
I've met plenty of ex-military you know
actually I have yet to meet a single
terrorist actually you know I've become
Muslim I'm practicing religion I go to
10 20 30 different messages since I've
been Muslim you know too many to count
I have yet to meet a terrorist so you
know anybody tries to say oh yeah you
have thousands of terrorists you know
there's two billion Muslims what is that
you know like it's like a decimal point
five zeros and then the 1% get up it's
something that definitely people
perceive it to be something that's
common but it's not you know even the
FBI said only six percent of terrorists
are actually Muslim so as much as the
news types it up it's not much really I
haven't met one in Islam's never taught
me to blow anything up so this lom's
never taught you to blow anything up
but it's taught you how to live a good
rice righteous wholesome life let's talk
about that the purity of Islam Islam is
definitely the fact talk this long I was
yeah yeah after converting to Islam I
was a little bit afraid to tell my
family my friends there was a lot of
negative stigma
despite hate the peaceful teachings
despite the good way of life and morals
of Islam there was still a stigma you
know the it was you know it was worse
than anything else you could tell your
family hey I became Muslim so maybe for
about four months you know I I was
learning the religion slowly at the time
you know I didn't know I remember eating
some pork a couple weeks after becoming
Muslim in a Muslim online say hey what
you do you don't allow to do that so you
know I learned over time
bit by bit but finally when I told my
family you know I wasn't eating pork and
they last one it came out that hey I'm
Muslim so you know there was a tough one
or two months even my parents you know
they said this is just a face when you
go back to the military this coming
summer you know you're gonna come back
to normal they thought it was you know
like a teenager going through a phase
and then after going to the military you
know I definitely had some run-ins with
people since I declared my religion is
Islam what my dog tags and everything
that was the first summer after 9/11 so
there was a lot of people who
voluntarily joined the army just the
fight Muslims and here I was the only
Muslim in the basic training unit and it
was definitely an experience but you
know people ask that all the time even I
had a drill sergeant asked me when we
get out on the battlefield which ways
you're going to get a point you know are
you the enemy are you one of our actual
soldiers you know so a lot of people
have this stigma so I mean the
perception is that being a Muslim
instantly makes you the enemy like I've
talked about before the US vs. them
mentality so in the military even though
I was wearing the uniform even though I
was standing in line next to them some
people perceived as the enemy and you
know like I said this was months after
9/11 so some of it was to be expected
after getting back from the military you
know family friends a lot of them cut me
off
they thought like okay it's not a phase
still again the 911 stigma floating
around I ended up having to leave my
home city at that time and move in with
him there was a Muslim brother I met
through Joseph somebody else and I moved
down to Virginia and one of the best
things I did is a new Muslim even though
that was maybe nine months after
becoming Muslim was I moved in with a
roommate a very good Pakistani brother
the name Salman and I moved from Erie
which had no Muslims basically to
Virginia charity you know many messages
in the DC area and one of the best
things was able to go to a Masjid meet
Andy ma'am be involved in a community so
as a new Muslim being involved in an
active community was one of the things
that really allowed me to start learning
my religion and that's when I started
growing the beard and learning that this
Easter certain things are obligated by
Allah I grew my religion by being part
of a community and going to classes and
that was probably one of the best things
I feel before that you know I did feel
alone but hamdullah
although was always with me Maya through
the military and other things but if I
have one advice to like new Muslims is
that definitely trying to be involved in
the community makes a big difference
because those nine months alone
was very hard but as soon as you have a
community with you know you feel then
you're no longer alone yes you always
have a love it
having very new Muslim there's a lot to
learn there's a lot to understand and
sometimes having the support is very
very crucial pressure we're going to
talk about I got two more points and
because we're almost out of time we're
going to talk about faith chat in a
second after this last question so what
was it about Islam that had you go
against all the odds that had you
finally accepted the main thing really
uh like I said when I first read about
Islam I was trying to reaffirm my
Christian faith throughout the whole
thing I was reading just to understand
the enemy basically but part of it I
read early Christian history I'm
thinking like the Muslims claim that
Mohammed is a prophet that came after
Jesus they believed in Jesus so I read
the early Christian history what
happened after Gigi is this how the
Bible came to be you know three four
centuries later and actually read the
story of salman al-farsi at one point he
was a christian scholar from persia and
you know is even his brother priests and
stuff
that you know the message of Jesus is
lost there's gonna be a new prophet that
will come and revive it and we know even
in the Old Testament that when the
message of a prophet would bait a new
prophet will come to revive the message
you know wasn't something that was
illogical or anything so the early
Christian history combined with the fact
that what the Muslims were speaking and
teaching just made perfect sense I found
it to be the truth nothing else I didn't
care about our Muslim terrorists that
point at one point I just felt you know
this is the truth and I ended up telling
myself at one point that while I'm
reading these articles on it slump I'm
convinced already so when am I gonna
become a Muslim you know for maybe one
day I was thinking like no I can't be
Muslim I'm white but you know eventually
it was just kind of a gradual process
reading and learning I realized this is
the truth and then I accepted that last
last thing I want to talk about we have
30 seconds left tell us about the new
Muslim Academy and also where people can
hook up with you at faith chat com
actually one of my first teachers in
Virginia you said big Greece he runs the
new Muslim Academy it's one of the best
online resources for after the Shahada
before the Shahada and you're not a
Muslim yet faith com we have live team
some articles and we try to spread the
message of Islam to those who don't know
it yet just like I did it at one point
so if anyone has any questions now maybe
that person is a blind hater but they
like what we have to say they're really
inquisitive now they want to learn more
they can hook up with you at faith chat
calm yes okay thank you so much for
being with us brother it was a pleasure
peace be with you a Salam alaikum thank
you ollie for being with us here on the
Deen show what an incredible story don't
forget new Muslim Academy comm and if
you want to hook up with him faith chat
com I get fascinated every time I hear
an individual come on and share their
story because there are so many people
with out a doubt Islam is something
rational logical and if you look into it
you put this blind hatred as racism this
animosity that you might have that's
really based on a false fear but like he
did he really looked into Islam he
looked at the evidence of it it's pure
message of monotheism
it's called to do good to live a
righteous life doesn't call you to blow
yourself up or anybody doesn't call you
to terrorism and all this other all
these other things that are associated
with it and with all the negative
propaganda it still continues to be the
fastest growing way of life in the world
why is that why is that you got to ask
yourself so you learned that you know
once he saw the similarities he saw that
Islam submission to the will of the
Creator not the creation that he saw
calls Muslims to believe in Moses
Abraham Jesus the last the final mr.
prale Muhammad peace be upon him and you
could put it all together from the
beginning that they didn't come with
different religions they all came with
the same simple message the same way of
life that you submit yourself entirely
to the one who created you
you don't worship a man a woman a stick
a stone a bone no Jesus peace be upon
him who we love and revere he never it's
a lie if you've been taught that you've
been brought up to believe that he's God
a literal son of God this is a blatant
lie he never wise it alighted he because
Jesus never ever called people to
worship himself he was sent by God with
a message from God calling the people to
worship God don't make it out to be
something it isn't and don't put words
in his mouth because Jesus peace be upon
him he was subordinate to God he
worshiped God he prayed to God he ate
food and went to the bathroom he wasn't
God and he wasn't a literal son of God
he was a mighty Messenger of God and if
you can understand because this is the
crossroads this is where we go to the
right and other people they end up going
in a direction that's not based on any
proof or evidence just blind following
and this gentleman here who was with us
he wasn't about to do any blind
following he looked at all the evidence
he scrutinized it and he saw that Islam
provided Islam remember it's just an
epic word that means submission to the
will of God and Jesus he didn't speak
English he spoke Aramaic which is a
sister language to Arabic and he called
on Allah the Creator God Almighty Allah
so look too much to mention in this
short amount of time but Islam is simply
a way of life that calls you to have a
relationship a loving relationship with
the one who created you the one who made
you the one you're going to return back
to so call on the one
the one who will never let you down and
we believe he's the most just and loving
and he wouldn't leave you without
guidance if you asked so ask the one who
made you for guidance and continued to
tune in to the Deen show this life is
short you got to figure it out what's
the purpose of light what's the meaning
of life why have I been created why am I
here just to accumulate a lot of wealth
and money party and I know there's more
to life think about it think about it
follow us subscribe to the Deen show and
as you can see I get really excited
talking about Islam because it makes
sense it really makes sense it'll make
sense to you if you just look into it
put this blind hatred animosity or you
picked up maybe through the media of Fox
News or many of these other outlets and
tune in to the deed show every week so
you can learn more and you can be
enlightened that's right and a whole new
world will open up we'll see you next
time inshallah God willing until that
peace be with you